joining us tonight is a man who did more
for East Palestine Ohio than Joe Biden
Mr Benny Johnson
I'm really sad that that's true but it
is absolutely verifiably empirically
correct and you did a lot for a single
American individual but in the grand
scheme of things giving twenty thousand
dollars out is like as low as it can be
you know so it's like for you as a
single person that's a huge that's huge
for Joe Budden the federal government it
is sad they did nothing at all yeah this
is like
um not even Nancy Pelosi's plastic
surgery bill for a Wednesday
what was uh what'd you use the money for
what do they use the money for I'm not
sure did you just say it was like a gift
it was a gift people it was Cash do you
have a foundation that does it
we just took our we took uh our profits
uh for the month and we went up to East
Palestine and we handed those people an
envelope with a thousand dollars in it
we went to Google Maps and we found
where the crash site was then we went to
the homes that were closest to the crash
site